[Music]
you may know a lot about the human body
thanks to your biology class but there
are a few things your teacher may have
skipped would you believe that you are
actually 90% cats stay tuned to see how
if you're new to our channel click the
red subscribe button and give this video
a big thumbs up today we are revealing
10 things you didn't know about the
human body
kissing fights cavities there is more
reason than ever to lay one on your
significant other kissing can actually
help fight against cavities when you
kiss someone you are producing more
saliva which is great for your oral
health saliva helps prepare small cares
improve enamel but even though it sounds
like a lot more fun
kissing shouldn't replace brushing and
flossing pinky toes are useless thanks
to evolution many parts of the body are
now useless one of these useless body
parts is your pinky toe since we no
longer use our feet to grip trees our
pinky toes are slowly losing their
significance scientists even predict
that humans 500,000 years from now will
have enough like bestows that don't grow
toenails we are 90% cat you have 99.9%
of the same genetic makeup as the person
sitting next to you but some other
species share your genetic coding as
well our closest genetic relatives are
chimpanzees at 96% similar genetic
makeup and believe it or not you have a
lot more in common with your cat and you
thought in 2007 studies found that Alba
skinny and domestic cat share 90% of
their genes with humans broken hearts
are real if you have ever lost someone
you love then you know the pain of a
broken heart
and it's not just a metaphor science has
proven that broken hearts are real
people who experience a sudden loss are
41% higher risk of heart attack or
stroke the risk is even higher the first
one to two weeks after the sudden loss
bellybutton rainforest no bellybutton
rainforest isn't a title of a cool new
dance moves sweeping the Internet
science has found that your belly
buttons bacteria makes ascent ecosystem
similar to rainforests this is because
like rain forest each bellybutton has a
bacterial
systems that is unique to the individual
but there are a few bacteria like trees
in a rain forest that show up in
everyone's bellybutton you smell
difference with age have you ever known
as well bogeys have a certain smell no
we aren't talking about their diapers
there are chemical compounds in our
bodies that help seems information via
our smell this means you can identify
someone's age by the way of their do it
has everything to do with sweat glands
baby smells listen because of the
chemicals in their sweat fans said to
secure when they get older
according to research older people also
had a pleasant smell because the older
you get the less body odor you have body
regeneration if your new year's
resolution was to become a new person
your body has you covered
your body completely replaces itself
every five to seven years and there are
some pretty impulsive numbers behind the
madness you have a new liver every six
weeks and a new skeletal structure every
three months but the most impressive
speed is at the fact that your brain
completely replaces itself every two
months conference you may not think much
of your tongue other than that it helps
you taste but your tongue can actually
help identify you your individual tongue
prince is as unique as your fingerprint
there is even a tongue print while abase
in japan considering people aren't
flocking to give their tongue prints the
database isn't going to solve any crimes
anytime soon slabs doesn't mean not fit
if you've ever given yourself a nice
slap on the belly and notice a little
jiggle that doesn't mean you don't have
abs we feel when it comes to having a
strong core having a six-pack doesn't
matter because of this it may be hard to
see your strong core underneath so don't
fret if you aren't seeing abs poking
through you'd have to have less than 10
percent body fat to do so you have
animals on your face don't freak out but
you have something on your face no it
isn't leftover lunch it's just a
microscopic might there are two
different species of microscopic mites
that call human faces home our faces
have largest pores than the rest of our
bodies which is where these mites like
to check out the science isn't really
sure why everyone has these face mites
the good news is they are harmless which
of these human
are you most surprised by let us know in
the comment section below and check out
10 amazing kids you won't believe
actually exist
[Music]
you
[Music]